you've seen these photos well the
current situation at our southern border
is completely out of hand that caravan
of Central American migrants that
started at a thousand strong is now down
to about two hundred people or so and
many of them are camped out at just a
stone's throw from the US customs
checkpoint at San Ysidro now as we've
been reporting the aliens are being
coached in some cases by American
lawyers traveling to the caravan and
telling them how to qualify for asylum
now this undoubtedly infuriates many of
you who would also love free legal
advice would that be nice the President
as well is totally fed up he tweeted
this week that the migrant caravan that
is openly defying our border shows how
weak and ineffective u.s. immigration
laws are I'll say well yesterday u.s.
customs officials allowed eight members
of the caravan into the country to
process their Asylum claims today
another 17 were allowed in the acting
director of immigration Customs
Enforcement
Tom Holman he described the situation on
Fox & Friends this morning I think it's
an attack on the sovereignty of this
nation look do I think some of these
people have a credible fear case--it's
do some of these folks are they escaping
for persecution yes some are but I also
know that many irons and many are taking
advantage of a system with loopholes in
it well he's absolutely right many of
these people are being taught to game
the system but what are the forces
fueling the migrant rush to the borders
let's start with the facts it's really
important that we all understand what's
really playing out here
this mini surge of humanity 200 or so
it's playing out on our television
screens every day it's just a drop in
the bucket compared to the massive
influx of entire US family units and
unaccompanied minors who cross the
southwest border between October 2017
and March of this year look at those
numbers now the number of migrants also
from Honduras Guatemala and El Salvador
those numbers have climbed significantly
in recent years even as Mexican
migration has declined so Mexico is
going down and that part of the the
continents going up hmm now immigrants
both legal and illegal originally from
El Salvador Guatemala northern triangle
that rose by 25% from 2007 to 2015 again
even as the figure dropped by six
percent for Mexican immigrants now of
the three million northern triangle
immigrants living here as of 2015 a
whopping 55 percent were illegal
according to the Pew Research Center now
by comparison only 24 percent of all
other immigrants in the United States
were unauthorized so more than double
the figure for the northern triangle
countries now there are many
facilitators many supporters and many
magnets for this migration scheme both
inside and outside America now here at
home the forces are powerful to
encourage this crush at the border the
chamber of commerce they want more
workers agricultural interests obvious
reasons sanctuary cities and states they
see future voters and maybe even
taxpayers well ms-13 and other gangs
looking for new recruits human
traffickers they love the situation at
the border and of course the drug
cartels but political interests in
Central America are also driving the
poorest of the poor northward these
government's want the poor and of course
they're criminals to leave the country
now it seems counterintuitive for a we
as Americans a country wanting its own
people to leave huh doesn't make any
sense
well meet the Honduran ambassador to
Mexico all didn't Rivera Montes he
marched with the caravan I kid you not
he went and marched with a caravan in
mid-april and here's what he told El
Universal about his participation he
said I've been ordered by my government
to support the Honduran migrant
traveling with the caravan there are
about 200 Hondurans who we will help out
with paperwork and whatever is necessary
Oh is an ordered by his government to do
whatever is necessary
well one might expect that the constant
drain right from the populations of the
northern triangle would debilitate their
economies hey thank you have a drain of
people well that's not the case in fact
the money called remittances sent by
migrant laborers from the United States
back to Guatemala back to Honduras and
back to El Salvador is massive and
growing now look at the remittances
going from the u.s. to Guatemala loan in
2009
Guatemala is here in the United States
sent nearly four billion dollars back
home this past year reached eight point
one nine two billion that figure so
double and they are up four percent in
the first quarter of this year so it's a
bump up in Honduras remittances are up
to more than as well four billion
dollars a year they've actually risen
eighteen percent the first month of 2018
this makes them up nearly 17 percent
listeners this is 17 percent of the GDP
of Honduras Honduras
so the remittances just so you
understand are 17 percent of the economy
of the whole country of Honduras no
wonder what they want them to keep
coming for El Salvador
it's nearly sixteen percent of their GDP
so the remittances are a huge economic
boon to these poor countries so why
would any third-world nation focus on
solving problems at home when it's so
much easier to export their neediest to
the United States and at the same time
for those poor countries to benefit from
their remittances when they send the
money back home look there is just
madness and there are some definitive
steps that we can take in the meantime
to remove these in
sentence now why should illegal
immigrants living in the United States
be able to send cash home to families
with zero government tax from the United
States government now why not slap a I
know a 25 percent levy on each
remittance that leaves America that wall
ooh
a lot more it could be funded really
fast ditto for foreign aid well what am
I talking about one 2017 we sent Mexico
El Salvador Guatemala and Honduras a
combined total of five hundred and
eighty seven million dollars in foreign
aid oh and two especially the the
northern triangle countries get their
acts together you know root out their
own corruption start improving the lives
of their own people
we we should consider at least
withholding some and some people are
saying all foreign aid sounds harsh but
god something's got to change here folks
this border busting and asylum fraud is
an insult to every American taxpayer
every legal immigrant a rule of law and
if Tom Holman said on Fox and Friends
our sovereignty and it is time for us to
stop subsidizing the lawlessness if you
ask me it's the American people who need
asylum these days asylum from the
politicians who got us into this mess in
the first place and those in Congress
over on Capitol Hill who refuse to do
what's necessary to secure the homeland
and that's the angle